One transform matrix worth a quick
mention is the mirror matrix,
also called the reflection matrix.
This matrix usually has one element here
be a -1, and the other two are ones.
For example, here's a mirror matrix
that mirrors the Z coordinate.
This transform makes the Z axis
act something like a mirror.
Anything on one side of the axis
is mirrored to the other.
You can create a mirror matrix
easily enough in three.js
by setting a scale value to -1.
There are in fact an infinite number of
mirroring matrices since by rotation and
translation you can move
the mirroring plain.
One major problem with the mirroring
matrix is that it not only flips
the triangle it also flips
the sense of the triangle.
Using the mirroring matrix converts
from a right handed coordinate
system to a left handed one or
vice versa.
That is in a right handed system
a triangle's vertices normally
proceed counter clockwise
around its edge.
After a mirror matrix,
this order's reversed.
If you're using backface culling, for
example, you have to reverse the culling
sense from making the front side
visible to the back side visible.
Even with this, I find that mirroring
matrices are tricky to use in three.js.
By default,
the reversal also affects lighting,
for example, making it look like lights
are coming from the opposite direction.
Maybe you'll have better luck and
if so put it in the forums.
One place where mirroring sometimes
is used is when modeling.
Instead of sculpting a whole moth,
for example, you can make half a moth.
You then use a mirror matrix
to create the other half.
Sometimes you might encounter
a matrix in a data file and
don't know where it came from.
It might be a mirror so
that could really mess you up.
You can use the matrix for
a determinant call to see if there's
any mirroring in the matrix.
If the determine is negative,
it contains a mirror.